let's talk a little bit about we are
just asking questions we are just asking
questions I'm going to play you a clip
from CNN of James Comer being
interviewed by Caitlin Collins
and confronted about a conspiracy theory
he floated about the Chinese balloon
take a look at this one thing you said
as we were learning about this balloon
and try
and Trent takeoff from muhan we don't
know anything about it but you don't
have any evidence that this guy I asked
a question I mean what is in the balloon
this is something that we believe the
the White House should have uh
advise us on they should have had a
briefing to tell us what this was I mean
back home in Kentucky this is all
anybody talks about what was this blue
everyone was concerned in Kentucky it
was all ballooned 24 7. yeah no one
trusts China they know China is an
adversary my concern was the military
had no idea anything about the balloon
what was in the balloon uh where was it
a spy balloon was it a weather balloon
like China said what exactly did the did
the U.S military know about this what
did our intelligence know about this did
they know it was even in airspace before
it got in the Alaska airspace so you
know it's just a lot of questions and
that was just one of the questions just
for all we know it could have bio
weapons in it they could be testing
evidence no no I didn't I asked a
question he's just asking questions sort
of like I could say is James Comer a
pedophile bank robber who secretly
spends his time producing child porn why
hasn't anyone investigated it why Won't
Anyone investigate it well be David
because there's no evidence of that I'm
just asking questions as a phrase has
become a really common defense for
people who promote conspiracy theories
but it's actually a dangerous
weaponization of free speech because the
idea behind I'm just asking questions is
I'm seeking information
I'm not promoting anything false by
asking a question how could I it's just
a question I'm asking a question because
I seek information but that's of course
not the case when it comes to a lot of
these conspiracy theories the people who
are just asking questions are asking
questions as a way to promote false
baseless sometimes harmful ideas without
having to take the responsibility for
the consequences of floating those ideas
someone might say I'm just asking
questions have you ever considered that
the moon landing was faked why haven't
you considered it whatever and when you
look at the intent of that it implies
there's reason to support the conspiracy
theory when in fact there's overwhelming
evidence to show actually the moon
landing was real and the problem with
this type of rhetoric is that it lets
the false information spread without
being challenged because at the end of
the day what's wrong with asking a
question and it also creates a false
equivalency between here are the
established facts and here are just
these are questions and they're just as
valid well actually there are questions
with the intent to promote a conspiracy
theory and uh when someone says I'm just
asking questions we can evaluate their
intention why is it that they are asking
this question and not a different one
why is Comer asking remember he doesn't
have evidence for any of this stuff why
is he asking were there what what did he
say were there bio weapons versus were
there tootsie rolls right both would
just be questions no evidence for either
why is he asking one but not the other
well you have to go and look at his
intent and the intent of course is to
sew exactly this type of uh concern
about the Biden Administration